call me dude Z and we're having a good  time here on doozy dwdz dudes EFM hey  it's ten thousand on your fm dial we got  Chad coach in the studio hilarious guy  incredible uh writer and podcaster and  uh all right everybody hey we got news  traffic weather and sports coming up  it's 8 15. quarter after the hour  sitting here with Chad coaching hey Chad  go ahead Chad go tell us a little bit  about those micro decisions what's that  all about uh micro decisions are very  tiny decisions that you make billions of  a day that together coalesce into one or  two big decisions yeah I have a little  bit of what he's smoking hey I'll tell  you tell you what we got the stick super  set coming up hey what's it like working  with that guy was that Mad TV guy I  heard he replaced already like hey  what's going on with Artie Lange you  know already Lang hey guys hey you know  already like hey uh with that other fat  guy Wilson replaced was that how fat is  he  yeah how fat is that guy